[Music]
oh
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
do
[Music]
so
[Music]
[Music]
know hello
[Music]
in my head
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
please
[Music]
[Music]
now
bye
every man
in the morning
that he's a macho man
oh
oh
[Music]
[Music]
always look forward
he's a macho man
my
uh
hey
[Music]
oh
[Music]
[Music]
everybody
special
[Music]
oh
hey
[Music]
so
[Music]
it ain't me
[Music]
it ain't me
oh
[Music]
look at me
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
love life but i was just
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
for is press still hounded you all the
papers had to say
was that marilyn was found
and it seems to me
[Music]
when the rain
[Music]
long before
[Music]
goodbye
[Music]
yourself
[Music]
when the rain
[Music]
legendary
you can burn
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
i pray you'll be on
and watch us
[Music]
when we lose
to place
[Music]
[Laughter]
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
give us
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
and is us
[Music]
just like every
[Music]
give us
[Music]
[Applause]
all right
[Music]
is
[Music]
is
[Music]
just before dawn through a silence
you feel you could cut with a knife
announces the cat
who can now be reborn and come back
to a different evangelical life
[Music]
oh
[Music]
turn memory face
if you find there a meaning of what
happened
[Music]
i can smile
i was beautiful then
i remember a time
i knew what happened was
[Music]
[Music]
i must wait for the sunrise
i must think of the new life
and i mustn't give
when the dawn comes
[Music]
[Music]
and
[Music]
[Music]
is
[Music]
is
[Music]
[Music]
is
me you'll understand what happiness
[Music]
is
please
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
it's nine o'clock on a saturday
a regular crowd shuffles in
there's an old man sitting next to me
making love to his sonic and gin
he says son can you play me a memory
i'm not really sure how it goes
but it's sad and it's sweet and i knew
it complete
when i was
sing us a song you're the piano man
sing us a song tonight
well we're all in the mood for
you got us feeling all right
[Music]
now john at the bar is a friend of mine
he gets me my tricks for free
and he's quick with a joke or to light
up your smoke
but there's some place that he'd rather
be
he
as a says ran away from his face
but i'm sure that i could be a movie
star
if i could get out of this
[Music]
now paul is a real estate novelist who
never had
time for a while
and he's talking with david who's still
in the navy
and probably will be
[Music]
and the waitress is practicing politics
as the businessmen slowly get stoned
yes they're sharing a dream they call
loveliness
but it's better than drinking alone
[Music]
sing up
[Music]
and you've got us
[Music]
it's a pretty good crowd for a saturday
and the manager gives me a smile
cause he knows that it's me they've been
coming to see
to forget about life for a
[Music]
and while bread in my jar and say man
what are you doing here
[Music]
and you've got us feeling all right
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
hold on
well if you told me you were drowning
but i don't know who i am
[Music]
[Music]
i know where you've been
[Music]
oh
[Music]
oh
[Music]
[Music]
is the first time
the last time
[Music]
[Music]
me
[Music]
[Music]
oh
[Music]
[Music]
oh
[Music]
[Music]
hello
[Music]
[Music]
hello
[Music]
hey
i'm doing this tonight
[Music]
now it's time to leave
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
me
[Music]
[Music]
just hit me with
[Music]
[Music]
now i really come to
would be much better
ladies and gentlemen the president of
the united states
donald j trump
[Music]
today
god bless the usa
[Music]
from the lakes of minnesota
to the hills of tennessee
across the plains of texas
from see the shining sea
from detroit down to houston
where there's pride in every american
heart
and it's time we stand and say
[Music]
that i'm allowed to be an american
where at least
[Music]
today but your rainbow down
[Music]
and i won't forget the men who died
next to you and defend her still today
[Music]
and i won't forget the men who died
[Music]
god bless the
[Music]
from the lakes of minnesota
to the hills of tennessee
across the plains of texas
from sea to shining sea
from detroit down to houston
and new york to valencia
where there's pride in every american
heart
and it's kind we stand and say
[Music]
who died who
and i gave stand up next to you
and defend her still today
[Music]
[Music]
i'm
[Music]
next to you and defend her still today
[Music]
[Applause]
well thank you very much pittsburgh a
great place
you have always treated me well thank
you pittsburgh
thank you very much i'm thrilled to be
back in the commonwealth of pennsylvania
with thousands of loyal
hard-working american patriots and by
the way
the home of the pittsburgh steelers
congratulations
good team great quarterback don't you
think i think he's good
big ben right big fan he's a good man
he's a good man
42 days from now we're going to win
pennsylvania and we're going to win
four more years in the white house
[Music]
and we're all entitled to it i will tell
you that
with your vote we're going to lift our
nation to
extraordinary new heights we're going to
turn the page forever on the failed
political class so that's exactly what
we've been doing
and we're going to defend our jobs our
families our borders
and our treasured way of life
and remember we now put
america first we do it
for a long time it's been a long time
this is the most important election in
the history of our country i believe
that
and this election is a matter of
economic survival for pennsylvania
you had the greatest year you've ever
had last year and you're
really in your way we were very very
sadly disturbed
by what happened with china they left
the plague out
they shouldn't have done it
but you're now on your way we close it
up we saved millions of lives that's the
bottom line
we closed it up we saved millions of
lives
and i will tell you you see what's
happening you see the numbers as well as
i do
you are on your way to i think maybe
economically the best year this next
year will be the best year we've had
and the third quarter where do you look
at the third quarter look at the numbers
they will be out before the election but
i predict they'll be
very good by the way if they're not i
deny a episode
i deny but i'm pretty confident they're
going to be incredible probably the best
ever under my administration
we proudly achieved energy independence
[Applause]
and don't forget i am not the candidate
two two candidates that said
we're not gonna have fracking we're
gonna ban fracking and he said that for
a year
then all of a sudden he said well maybe
we'll have some fracking by the way you
know that's not gonna last cuz a radical
left
won't let him get away with it and i'm
all for fracking you know i was in texas
i well it's a big part of your economy
it's energy it's
it's uh just a tremendous part but i was
in texas two weeks ago
and my opponent is against oil
guns and god
and i just spoke to the governor of
texas greg abbott a great guy he said i
think you're up 15
sir i said well the fake news says i'm
up four
i said he said united four and i wanted
by a lot last night remember last time
with you with texas with many states
it's too close to call we don't know and
then boom the polls slows they say trump
won trump when trump won
we won a lot and
and i won pennsylvania because of you i
won pennsylvania and you had your best
year so i mean that's the way it's
supposed to work
and i think we're going to win a lot
don't forget last time i came in i said
i was going to give you the tax cuts
that's regulation cuts
i said we're going to do big things with
energy big things with steel
your steel mills every one of them would
have been closed in god
had i not won but i said i was going to
do all these things so it's tougher
now i've done everything i said and more
i've done more i've done
more than i said so this should be
easier and i hear we're doing really
well
i know we're doing really well based on
uh you know we came in with a lot of you
great congressman i said how we doing
they said you're going to win it by a
lot
but we better win it we got to go out we
got to vote
powered by the incredible workers of
your state
you are now really if you look at it
the number one producer think of it
we are as a nation your state is you
have no idea how big it energy you know
how big you are in energy people don't
think of pennsylvania that way
do you have any do you have any idea
[Applause]
and as a nation we're the biggest in the
world by far
not even close and we are energy
independent think of that
[Applause]
but no longer is america at the mercy of
these foreign suppliers and
all of the people that took advantage of
us for so many years we now don't have
to be in other parts of the world
we're there perhaps to help allies we're
there perhaps to help
good people but we're not there because
we need their energy because we need
their oil
instead we're the dominant energy
producer we're going to keep it that way
we're going to always have it that way
this by the way our opponents
they don't want petroleum products okay
they want
wind let's open up wind let's have some
wind and every once in a while the wind
will blow and you'll produce
a couple of things and then you can then
you can close down your plant for the
rest of the season
you can watch those birds fly out of the
sky
too i always say it's a bird graveyard
under the windmill
doesn't have the power it doesn't have
the staying power
you see what's happening in california
blackouts rolling blackouts
how would you like that in pennsylvania
the commonwealth of pennsylvania
darling what's wrong i can't watch trump
on television
i can't watch our president daryl we
have a roll back out
it'll only be a few hours i think we'll
be on by two o'clock in the morning
darling and we can watch your rerun
now this is what's happening you have
rolling black out you have
in some cases just blackouts i don't
even call them
not gonna happen to your state last year
i visited the shell
petrochemical plant in beaver county
pennsylvania
the largest investment in your state
history
and that was all made possible by our
pro-energy policies
and we've done it a lot in louisiana
we're building some of the largest
the largest plants you've ever seen
largest in the world and it's incredible
all related to energy
but your security and your jobs are in
very grave peril
because the left maniacs they don't want
to have anything to do with energy
they don't want anything to do with uh
they have different concepts right
uh they have the green new deal where
there will be no energy almost of any
kind
now it's it's crazy thought of by
aoc plus three you know a.s
[Music]
not a good student not good at anything
but she's got a good line of crap i'll
tell you that
she's got a hell of a lung
[Applause]
and she's got him you know she's radical
left but she's not as bad as some of
them
how about omar of minnesota
we're going to win the state of
minnesota because of her they say
she's telling us how to run our country
how did you do where you came from how
is your country doing they're going to
tell
she's going to tell us she's telling us
how to run our country
and you know what the democrats in
congress you have to see what they're
doing their stance on israel it's like a
whole different world
it's like from 10 years ago it's like a
different world
and we want to keep our world the way it
was and the way it's going to be
we've got the greatest country on earth
and we're going to keep it that way
we don't need socialists and we don't
need communists
telling us how to run our country
you know i do this every night and a lot
of times it's a waste i did it
last night we were did you see the crowd
we had last night
we were in a great place ohio and we had
a crowd
we had a crowd you couldn't see the end
of it and i said turn around
camera turn around but they never like
doing that you know they don't like
spinning those cameras they don't want
to show them
they don't like showing
they don't like showing show the crowd
and this is
it's an honor let me tell you
look you know i used to think there was
a difficulty like
it was a new camera that can't turn
but then whenever there was like a
problem like there'd be a little
argument or some kind of an anti-trump
person
you don't see that much i don't want to
bring it on but you don't see it much
anymore you know what
it's dangerous it's dangerous with it
but you know
i'd see the camera would never move but
everywhere there's something like a
little negative happening
that thing would turn around like a
pretzel
and i said oh it does move but they
never want to show
the crowds they never last night now i
went home and i tell you this i go home
all the time
first lady how'd you like the crowd sir
i didn't see it
i didn't see it but i didn't see it
donald i didn't see it sometimes you'll
call me mr president but she's only
kidding believe me
she's only kelly has she been a great
first lady right
and very popular she's really done a
great job and she works hard you know
we have some great people here tonight i
brought certain members of my family but
i'm going to introduce
them to you in the old way
great family they work hard i'll tell
you what they work hard
they really work hard but i do wish i do
wish they would show because it would be
you know it's actually better for them
if they show it shows the importance
the only thing you can do is it's true
i'll say
how did it look i don't know how it
looked but the sound was phenomenal okay
it sounded like a penn state football
game like a steelers
football game you know you can't
disguise it you ever see sleepy joe with
the little circles
he puts him very far away so far away
and then he comes up with the mask he's
like 100 yards from the nearest human
being he's got a
man he feels good about the mask i
wonder
in the debate it'll be him and i
are the stage is he going to walk into
the mask
[Applause]
i'll be honest he feels good about he
feels good about the mask and that's
okay you know what whatever makes you
feel good
he feels good how he feels i mean
honestly
what the hell do you spend all that
money on the plastic surgery if he's
going to cover it up with them
seriously the whole dude
[Music]
now i think he'll come in with a mask i
don't know you have no i have no idea
well the question is
will he leave it on during the debate
because it's a little hard
and i'm far from this when you need a
mama but when you're making a speech and
the nearest person's like where you are
and you're on a stage all by yourself
and then he had a habit of taking it off
and it hangs down on his ear
as he's speaking he feels comf it makes
him feel comfortable and you know
honestly whatever makes you feel good is
okay with me
but it'll be interesting and i'm going
to be we're going to have a big rating
on that and you know he's been doing it
all his life he's been doing it for 47
years and i've just started doing this
stuff
i'm sorry
but you know i'm just thinking but i did
more
in 47 months than he did in 47 years
you look at what we've done
no it's true that's actually true i did
a lot of negative stuff too you have to
deduct that out
when asked if there would be any place
for fossil fuels
including coal fracking in a biden
administration
joe replied no we would make sure that
it's all eliminated all of a sudden he
gets the nomination you know
he's been trying to get the nomination
for decades
he finally get and that was prime time
for him which was never great
and he never got more than one percent
we called him remember called him his
first nickname was one percent joe
and frankly had elizabeth warren been
loyal to her philosophy
which is radical left socialism perhaps
communism i don't know perhaps
it's verging on communism right but had
she been
loyal she would have left she would have
quit she had no chance she was out
pocahontas she was gone remember i said
i have more indian blood in me
than you have and i haven't and
i'd love to have some but i don't happen
to have any
and then she choked and she went out on
that test and she announced yet
twenty-fourth right one thousand that
means like
i said it last night that means around
seven or eight hundred years ago
somewhere there was a little bit of a
relationship going
that's okay seven eight hundred years
ago maybe
what a phony she is isn't she terrible
and now we're gonna pick a great woman
any one of the five that i told you but
any one of the women that we had they're
all great
people great scholars great brilliant
no they're all great women they're
brilliant great scholars by the way
while i'm here
would anybody prefer that i pick a man
is there any man that has the courage to
raise your hand
there's one right there i got one we
found one
no we're gonna pick an incredible woman
brilliant woman and
watch the abuse that she will take
whoever it's gonna the decision is gonna
be announced on saturday
five o'clock on saturday at the white
house
[Applause]
and you see we have tremendous
republican support
two people you know always got to be two
we've got to be the two those two we
have great support
from the republican party tremendous
support it's never been this unified
before
ever ever in the fake impeachment
we had 196 to nothing republican support
and we had 52 and a half
your body was very good today i have to
tell you it was good
now i'm
biden reiterated his pledge to require
net
zero carbon emissions that's basically
saying you know what that is
there'll be no more oil there'll be no
more gas there'll be no more nothing
there'll be no more
industry there'll be no more country
that's what it's like really
and that would instantly shut down all
fracking and all mining immediately in
pennsylvania
sending your jobs overseas sending your
money to somebody else not
you and i'll keep you jobs in
pennsylvania where they belong and
you're going to be doing fracking for a
long time
but i can say the same because you are
really big in energy and i can say the
same thing to you as i say in texas
so they don't want oil they don't want
fracking
right they don't want the energy that we
know that powers these massive plants
because the other stuff is wonderful
it's not going to do it it's not going
to do it
so they don't like oil they don't like a
gas
they don't like god religion churches
are close
how about these these states you know
they still have
uh churches and by the way your governor
hasn't been so great you know though
are your churches still clubs they're
still clowns
they're doing it for a reason by the way
november 4th they'll announce we've
decided to open up okay
they're trying to make our numbers as
bad as possible
so california is close pennsylvania
slows north carolina's laws
michigan is closed that's another beauty
right there
michigan's laws and then they have these
fake ballots millions and millions of
ballots by the way when
when not if when you see shenanigans
please report it to your authorities
okay
the real authorities they're watching
and the authorities are watching
but please report it but when you look
at it really it's amazing and they're
trying to make our numbers look bad
but even with numerous closed states and
you notice
also law and order right law the red
states
the republican states they're working
great
record low crime record low
but democrat run states
you look at chicago you look at new york
new york has gone through
we have to bring back we should draft
rudy giuliani
we want rudy
[Music]
but he did a great job new york was in
big trouble he came in and he
he just was tough smart and it became
the safest big city and now we have a
man
where some categories of crime were up
300 percent
he fired a thousand he fired a lot of
police
i guess a billion dollars a year worth
of
police worth of great police firemen
uh and women it's a it's a terrible
thing
i love that place so much and it's so
sad to see what's happening to new york
we're gonna make a little bit of a play
for new york you know in theory they
automatically the democrats
automatically win new york
but i do phenomenally in most parts and
then one part
uh it's automatic but i can't imagine
that particular part is going to be very
happy so we're going to make a play
for new york
with pennsylvania i don't have to make a
play we've got pennsylvania
[Applause]
we don't have to it's a great you know
for years though pennsylvania was a
place that
republicans just didn't win and for many
years
everybody thought they were going to win
every republican said yeah we're going
to win pennsylvania they thought
they were going to win it and they
didn't and i came along and we want it
and we want it quite easily
quite easily and i think we're going to
do even better now because remember
number one in the history of your state
last year and that's because of what we
did
we stopped the dumping we saved
pennsylvania is the home of american
energy think of it that way and this has
taken place over a very short period of
time also the birthplace
of a thing called the american
constitution
right american constitution
and to uphold our constitution as
written
as opposed to as conceived by some
radical left judge
i will soon be announcing that nominee
you're going to love it you're going to
be so happy if you don't love it don't
vote for me okay
you don't like it my opponent refuses to
release a list of justices you know
i uh i was told that
a big thing when i was running last time
nobody really knew me they knew me
very well we had great success at the
apprentice and in business and it was
great
but they never knew what kind of a judge
i would pick or
to be a justice right a justice of the
supreme court
and i said well let's i mean what am i
going to do am i going to solve that
problem but you know i was in politics
never don't forget when i ran they said
no he's inexperienced
you know and i ran against some very
talented people some of them
some of whom are very good friends of
mine some of whom i don't like too much
you know when i don't like somebody that
lasts for a long time but
i i said well how do we solve that
problem i don't know
they just weren't believing you know the
the appointment of
a united states supreme court justice
was much more important to the voters
than i thought and they're right
because they will set policy for 50
years
they'll set policy whether it's life
whether it's
second amendment your second amendment
if i weren't president you know the
pressure
your second amendment would be
obliterated it would maybe be gone
but at a minimum obliterated they
haven't touched your second amendment
not even touched it
because i'm here to block i'm a blocking
force i'm like
alignment for the pittsburgh steelers
i'm a blocking force no they haven't
touched it
but your second amendment would be
undersea so nobody knew
i never knew you know you hear about
supreme court you know about supreme
court you know about other judges by the
way at the end of
the first term we'll be close to 300
federal judges including court of
appeals
which i think is a record i guess it's a
record it's a lot
that's a lot nobody's done that and very
important that's a record three
think of that 300 that's a big
percentage of the entire
judiciary think of that 300 and uh
many many court of appeals judges but
two
great supreme court judges or justices
and
now we're going to get a third uh can
you imagine
can you imagine our enemies three in one
term
so many presidents they just don't have
the chance and it's so important but i i
said to my people i said so
if they don't believe me what i'll do is
i'll make up a list of 25 judges
and or people and will tell them i will
only pick from that list
they said that sounds like an
interesting idea this was my idea you
have to be
you know when you've never run for
office before you have to have a little
bit of imagination
so i got out on a list i named the
people the people that i said
and i promise that i will pick someone
like the people on this list
and it didn't work it went nowhere
because they didn't trust it if they
didn't trust they said we want you to
pick the people on the list
not somebody like the people so i went
back the next week i said
i will pick somebody that's on this list
they were all great great uh judges for
the most part i think almost entirely
but judges
and really respected conservative uh
believers in our country
solid incredible people and as soon as i
did that things went through the roof it
was amazing how important it was
by the way would you stand up with that
beautiful jacket i love that
i love this guy how many times
how many events he's been to a couple
that's really great thank you very much
i've seen him before he's been here a
couple of times like about 90.
thank you man that's really nice i'm
gonna get one of those jackets
by the way and you know the wall the
wall yeah
330 miles
330 miles
330 miles
and yes we have a great relationship
with mexico
and you know they keep saying yes first
they said he'll never be able to build
it because i had the
democrats were just brutal i made a
terrible mistake i said it last night
i should have said we will not under any
circumstances
build a wall at our southern border they
would have given me all the money in the
world
but stupidly i said we will build the
wall and the democrats said let's not
give it to him
but we got we won we won court cases we
won court cases
in fact i want so much money we can
build
four walls if we wanted
so then they said all right all right
we've
you know they've lost i mean so by the
way we're up in 330
the exact wall their their dream choice
you know i said to the border patrol i
love these people they're great ice the
border patrol
what they do is incredible they're
incredible i said give me your dream
wall as long as we're building it we
might as well build the wall that you
want let's build it right
sir we have to have vision we need steel
and concrete i said how about one or the
other
they said no sir we need steel and
concrete we need steel
and inside you know inside those poles
we have rebar and we have concrete right
and they're 30 feet tall we need all
sorts i think we need them to be wired i
mean i won't tell you why they're wired
but they're wired for a reason
they're all wired up and they're
incredible but you know what
uh we got the wall nobody could have
done it
so once we had the wall and it started
going up and then we hit 100 miles 200
miles
now we're at 3 30. and we're building 10
miles a week
and it'll be finished very soon
and we have the most secure border in
terms of
drug trafficking trafficking coming
along
and we've done phenomenally well because
that's a lot of the territory that we
need
we're going to go up to probably a
little bit over 500 miles so we're at
330.
but once they saw that i had it they
said
yeah but mexico is not paying for it
okay but they are paying for it mexico
is paying for the wall
they are paying for it they're paying at
the border they're paying for the wall
you know all those trucks that go back
and forth
they're paying for the wall so the
democrats said yeah but brexit they
always have to find something
right and you remember what i used to
say that
if they fight us remember people would
say what happens
if they fight you on the wall what
happens if they fight you right the hell
on the wall
i said the wall would get 10 feet taller
do you remember that
a little hit on that we took a little
bit of a hit but that's okay
the wall is a tall sucker you don't want
to get up to the top
they look down they say oh yeah yeah how
do we get that off
it's tall and it's strong and it's great
and we appreciate because mexico has
been working with us very closely
they have right now 27 000 mexican
soldiers on our southern border
making sure that people don't come into
our country
i want to thank the president of mexico
very helpful so i made this list of
potential justices and i'll tell you it
all changed now i'm asking sleepy joe
biden to give me a list
and he doesn't want to do it you know
why because he can only put
super radical left judges on people that
would destroy your country
people that would destroy your country
and he knows that he's not electable he
shouldn't be electable
anyway you know i mean he's the worst
candidate
you know where he is today they have a
thing called the lid
lid i don't even know do you know what
lid stands for lid
he put out a lid today early in the
morning lid means he's not going to be
anywhere today i'm working my ass off
i'm in
ohio i'm in texas i'm in florida i've
been michigan
i'm in wisconsin
[Applause]
wedding chelsea and also yoga
classes right right 33 000 emails on
yoga
and a wedding i don't think so
and comey said oh that's okay that
sounds like a
good reason that's comey that's another
beauty right there
well we caught him we caught him very
smart move
getting rid of that guy was a smart move
but we caught him
listen we caught him they were spying on
the campaign
they were doing actually worse than that
but there was nobody's ever done a thing
like this
so let's see what happens but we caught
them cold we got so much to
remember the inch the insurance policy
right
from strzok and page two lovers
you know they were very smart they would
uh use the public servers
that send it over the public wires
because they didn't want to be
caught having an affair so they went
over the public
that was a very good thing for us wasn't
it
darling darling darling please
she's going to win she's going to win
isn't she
peter peter only you can save us
peter she's going to win yes
darling she's going to win i know 100
000 to nothing remember that
actually it was actually 100 million to
one
so this was a hundred million to one
this is this
idiot so listen
so darling please please tell me again
yes 100 million to one she's going to
win
but just in case she doesn't
we have an insurance policy now that
only means one thing
and we went through the insurance policy
and we caught them
so let's see what happens to these
treasonous crooks
these terrible people and they put our
nation through
turmoil but i just want to thank a lot
of people were very unfairly treated
you look at general flynn look he's
still going through it can you believe
it
but a lot of people were unfairly
treated
by a bunch of treasonous horrible
people and they use the intelligence
agencies of our country
to try and steal an election and to try
and do
a coup when you think i mean who would
ever think this country
but that's all you can say i mean some
people would say well that's a
conspiracy theory no
just take a look at the records so i i
just it's just a very exciting for me
it's a very exciting thing
because we found something that nobody
would have thought possible now let's
see what happens but we have them called
they spied on our campaign it's our
campaign
[Applause]
and if you want to save america you have
to go out
get out and vote this is the most
important election
in just three and a half years we've
secured america's borders
which makes them very unhappy rebuilt
the awesome power
of the u.s military
we built the military it was totally
depleted when i took over
we built a military two and a half
trillion dollars we spent all made in
the usa the greatest equipment the
greatest planes and rockets and missiles
and our nuclear i hate to even mention
the word but and hope
to god we never have to use it but we
have the most powerful
weapons in the history of the world
and we did that over a very short period
of time
weapons that are so powerful
that we're the envy of the world but i
never want to use those weapons and
hopefully we'll never have to you know
the way you don't have to use them is
when you have them
it's when you have them but nobody's
ever built the force like what we have
and you know the uh the newspapers and
the press and the fake news they went
and said
he just gave away classified information
he said no i will look you right there
let me tell first of all i'm allowed to
do it i'm the president so i'm allowed
i'm the one i'm the only one that's
allowed
but no no i didn't give away i'm just
telling you most powerful
weapons ever produced we have
and other countries know that and it's a
good thing that they know it
and i don't think we'll ever be using
them and i hope we
don't i hope to god i use the word god
because they refuse to use the word god
in their pledge of allegiance right
christ
i use the word god i hope to god we
never have to use them
but i obliterated the isis caliphate
which was all over the place 100
remember i got it down to 99 they said
you got to go 100 i said let's get out
of here
we're bringing them all back home
everyone's coming back home
long long wars
the never-ending wars right the endless
wars
we fixed our disastrous trade deals they
were a disaster
brought jobs and factories back to
pennsylvania
under 16 years and think of this
16 think of this for 16 years presidents
obama president bush household income
rose
2 945
right that's over a 16-year period in
three years
your household income rose almost ten
thousand dollars when you include energy
you have to include energy
without energy almost seven thousand
dollars but we have to include energy i
mean how much are you paying for your
gasoline
you never saw two dollar gasoline you're
less right it's less
they go up it's less no it's
a big difference what is it nowadays
come on tell me i haven't got any guess
i haven't stopped recently at a gas
station i'm
15. okay because for a while it was uh
way under two and we're going to keep it
there we have so much we have so much
in my first three years we lifted 6.6
million people out of poverty the
largest poverty reduction
in the history of our country by far
we built the greatest economy in the
history of the world
and right now we're doing it again you
know it's i see all these heads
make america great again and now i'm
going to say this
make america great again again make
america great again again
we saved 1.4 million jobs in
pennsylvania alone
and to fight the china virus it's the
china virus that the coronavirus
corona sounds like a place in italy a
beautiful place it's corona
no it's the china virus they don't want
to say it you know the radical left they
don't want to say it
do you ever notice they're always going
after russia look
nobody's been tougher in russia than me
but yesterday russia russia russia
i said what about china they never want
to mention it you know
they got little deals going on i think
but
coronavirus doesn't sound like italy a
beautiful villa you have a beautiful
corona
now it's a china virus i should have
stopped it to fight the china virus we
launched the largest
national mobilization since world war ii
we did an incredible we did an
eight-plus job
except we did a d job in terms of
public relations explaining it because
we were too busy doing it
but the fact is they wouldn't have
written it anywhere it didn't matter to
them it's their it's their little thing
you ever watch joe biden he can't talk
about anything so it gets up
the uh the coronavirus
they say we want to talk about supreme
court judges today
well i don't know about that the
coronavirus
and he doesn't know we did a great job
he has no clue he said i should have
opened
so he goes i should have shut down one
week earlier what he doesn't say is he
did the worst job in the history of
an epidemic or a pandemic with the swine
flu it was a joke
and what he did what he did his own man
that was in charge
said recently we had no idea what the
hell we were doing
it was a total disaster there were
amateurs
and now he tells us how to do something
that's far more lethal
but he said they should have closed one
week
except when it came to closing the
border which i did
which turned out to save tens of
thousands of lives
biden criticized me until two months
later when he said i was right
but we should have closed a weaker think
of that we pioneered life-saving
therapies
reducing the fatality rate 85
since april think of that remdessevier
the plasma we have among the lowest case
fatality rates of any major country
nobody knows that
and i'm i am devastated to see it
happening but you see what's going on in
europe again you know they always said
oh europe is doing better actually
we did better but now europe has a big
spike
a big spike so they're not talking about
that
the number of hospitalized virus
patients is down by
47 percent and virus patients coming to
the emergency room
is down and visits a way down visits the
hospital
europe has almost a 50 greater excess
mortality rate than the united states so
you know they're likely to compare us to
europe
50 percent greater excess mortality rate
our early and aggressive actions save
millions of lives
through operation warp speed you've
heard about it they don't want to talk
about it what we've done
in a record period of time with the
ventilators and you know creating now
we're building ventilators
for the world very hard to do we'll
develop
and distribute a vaccine very very
shortly in record time it would have
been two or three years four years
if biden's group had done it but we've
done a great job with the fda and
clearing a path
and you'll be seeing it very shortly and
these are great companies that are doing
so we'll crush the virus and our
opponents will
with him they will crush america we
can't let it happen
this country is too great our love of
each other is too great
this guy doesn't know he's alive i mean
he really doesn't
he doesn't know he's alive you know he
did an ad on
a an anonymous source that said about me
making a statement about military
soldiers that died
and it was such a disgusting thing i
said the only good thing about it is now
i can take
the gloves off this guy doesn't have a
clue he doesn't know where the hell he
is
and they'll give him a shot or something
i don't know he's going to get something
he'll be
you know because i watched him so badly
he performed so badly in the debates and
then
with bernie he was average not great but
he got through
and i said what the hell is he taking
and we'd like to ask him and i said that
we want a drug test we want a drug test
we'll both take
they're both right because with bernie
he was able to get through but listen
i mean it wasn't winston churchill this
wasn't the greatest debate but he got
through was fine
him and bernie screaming at each other
mostly bernie crazy bernie he's not too
happy
i'll tell you did you ever see a better
loser than bernie though seriously he's
a good loser he
he got terribly treated by hillary and
that group
and then it happened again with
elizabeth warren right it happened again
what the democrat party did to him and
then you have this guy mike bloomberg
mini mike
one question he was gone there goes one
point eight billion out that window
i said you think it's easy up here mike
don't you
one question that i was in he said where
am i get me the hell off of this
platform
mini mike
so now he's trying to buy into the party
you would think after the way they
treated him they called him every name
pocahontas destroyed him she didn't do
good against me but boy did she do good
against minnie mike and
instead of i figured he'd be calling and
saying listen i want to become a
republican
you know we've done great for the
economy you'd think right
but he always wanted to run for
president and he tried before i guess
but he tried
and it was a bad experience and you
would think he would have joined our
party
but and said he's trying to buy his way
back in when somebody treats you that
way
even stay neutral don't go back in he
wants to give them a lot of money to try
and buy their friendship
and you know one thing you learned about
politics i spent
a fraction of the money that crooked
hillary spent they raised two billion
dollars i
spent i spent my own money but i spent a
fraction of the money
like 35 30
and we won nobody ever says that it's
not about money
it's about other things there are other
things involved it's not just about
money
you know in the old days my father would
teach you
if you can win and spend less
that's a good thing and i remember after
i won
and i won decisively look 306
to 223 that's a lot 306
delegates 306. that's decisive
we won michigan and we're going to win
it again we're up in a poll just now oh
they're going crazy
they're going crazy we won wisconsin we
won pennsylvania
but my father taught me he said if you
can win and spend less money that's a
good thing not a bad thing
that's a good thing not a bad thing like
if you get along with
the leaders of other lands and don't go
to war all the time with everybody and
can come out on top without having to
shed blood all over the place and
destroy your families and your country
like when i get along with putin when i
get along with kim jong-un whatever
happened to the war we were supposed to
be in with north korea nothing happened
they said i gave away so much i said
what did i give away they couldn't find
anything
i didn't do anything they said you met
oh i met oh okay that's
i met now you would have been in war
with her you would have been well but if
you can spend think of this
if you can spend less money and win
that's a good thing
so after i won one of these people back
there right back there
in order to keep the thing going on
trump i had one
he said but trump raised substantially
less money than crooked hillary clinton
that's because i didn't need the money
and i can call up a lot of rich guys and
raise a lot of money but i feel
uncomfortable doing it because when you
do that it's like you sort of it's not
the same
i could call up every guy they call me
up and they say
sir how are you sir mr president sir i
have frenzy
i don't have too many friends up because
i used to be comfortable you
have to be comfortable with people right
and i have friends i have one friend
richard i talk about them all the time
but they're
multiply this times 100 people and
richard used to call me up five six
years ago hey let's have dinner
all right where do you want to go i
don't know go to some crazy restaurant
today the restaurants are all closed in
new york they don't want to open them
they want to make them do badly until
november don't worry they're opening on
november 4th
but it's true so it's richard on the
phone richard my friend for many many
years
and i said hey rich mr president sir how
are you i said well
he's been calling me donny and don and
dj
and all richard are you okay everything
good
uh yes sir mr president sir you're doing
a great job and
i'd like to thank you good richard
richard listen up please you don't have
to call me mr president
i said so just call me donald it's okay
thank you donald i really appreciate it
and you hear the guy he can't breathe
you know he's having a hard time
breathing
he's very nervous and then at the end of
the phone he goes mr president again
thank you so much for the job you did
hang up i said
how can you be friends with you know it
just doesn't work it's like
i've lost a lot of people this way and
it's called respect for the office they
have respect for the office they really
do
nothing wrong with it sort of understand
that
they have respect for the office and
nobody has more respect for this
officers
than i do and that's why i'm doing a
great job and i'll always do a great job
disrespectfully
but on november 3rd pennsylvania will
decide
whether we end the pandemic defeat the
virus and return to
record prosperity just like we were
before
or whether we allow sleepy joe biden
who doesn't have a clue to kill the
recovery raise your taxes
delay the vaccine yes sir
he wants to impose a four trillion
dollar tax like you believe what tell
you
ban american energy which means what
let's go back let's call up the middle
east and let's be real nice
because we need their energy no thank
you destroy your suburbs you know i got
rid of this regulation that was going to
destroy your suburbs
destroy your suburbs the obama i call it
the obama regulations
they build nice projects right next to
your beautiful home lots of luck
give free healthcare i hope the people
in the suburbs when i did this i took a
lot of heat
i got rid of a regulation they all said
sir we'll amend the regulation we're
going to amend it
i said i don't want to re amend it and a
couple of stories were
i wish the women living in the suburbs
would read these stories
they were they were written by people
that say i can't believe
a president had the guts to do it i did
because i want to save the american
dream
and by the way a big part of the
american dream
are minorities who made it and they want
to live in the suburbs
and they don't want to be next to a
project
[Applause]
so all you people in the suburbs that
say i don't know i'm making up my mind
and cory booker was the one that was
going to lead it out
he was going to be the one he wants it
to be wants those projects to be nice
and big
and i just hope you i just hope you're
going to
remember that sooner than november 3rd
because you can do it sooner
give free health care to illegally so
the problem with free healthcare we all
have a heart
we all want to take care of people the
problem is when you promise free
education free health care
all this up but free health care
remember sleepy joe during the debate
who wants to give free health care to
illegal immigrants
and everybody immediately raises their
hand you know radical left
razor and joe do you remember there's a
classic he's
oh yeah
remember sleepy joe
and he'll do it because he has no choice
because they have total power he's like
a puppet for them
and indoctrinate your children with
poisonous anti-american lies
to combat the toxic left-wing propaganda
in our schools
i announced last week that we are
launching a new pro-american lesson plan
for students called
1776 commission
[Music]
we will teach our children the truth
about america
that we are the most exceptional nation
on the face of the earth and getting
better every single day we're not going
to let it fail
the democrat party has joined forces
with flag burners
anarchists anti-police people they're
extremists
agitators and then they say oh no no
this is a peaceful
this was a peaceful protest this is a
peaceful protest
they know what i'm talking about they
know our great uniform
brilliant we love them but you know what
we call it a peaceful protest now
because
the only thing you're allowed to do in
pennsylvania you can't go to church
right you can't meet you can't
congregate you can't look at each other
you can't give your wife's wife a kiss
goodnight you got to wear a mask
you can't do anything
they got you closed up don't go out to
dinner
stay where you are michigan same thing
like the governor
her husband went boating it was a
disaster because nobody's allowed he was
the only boat he had this massive
beautiful lake you know the lake i'm
talking about
it's a big lake and then a guy tried to
put a boat who is it it's the husband of
the governor and that was that didn't
work out too well for her
but the only thing you're allowed to do
is protest
and they have a line you can't go to
church
you can't be with your neighbors but if
you're going to protest and burn down
stores and loot stores and shoot people
and step on people's faces and do all
sorts of bad things that these people
will protect you from doing if they were
given their
their rightful power and dignity
[Applause]
[Music]
so if they have a clause stand up fellas
stand up
they've got to be able to do their job
you got to let them do their job
gotta be able to do your job right
they let you do your job you'd see you'd
see pennsylvania that's some
big bad crime numbers in your state you
let them do your job
any state new york's finest by the way i
got endorsed by new york's finest first
time they've ever endorsed
and you know that's hard when you have
radical left running the city all
politicians the mayor
and i got endorsed by the chicago police
can you imagine that
and i got endorsed by oklahoma and i got
endorsed by texas
and louisiana and i got endorsed by
florida the sheriff's
all the sheriffs got together they
endorsed trump i got endorsed by law
enforcement everybody
but how could you possibly endorse
people
that hate you and don't respect the job
you do and don't let you do your job
most importantly
because if they let you do if they let
you do
what you do better than anybody else in
the world you wouldn't have problems and
these are other police departments you
look at seattle
we said we're going in and they
immediately said
we'll put up our hands right we're so
easy we're going in the following day
you look at portland how about portland
it's like an anarchist stream
and we're trying we're dealing with the
governor because you know i hate to say
it but they're all
they're all democrat-run cities and
states all of them every single one the
republicans are doing great
but they have to ask by law they have to
ask us to go in
so we did it in minneapolis you saw that
but this is i mean it was too late was
it like 10 days
and the police are excellent but they're
not allowed to do their job
now they wanted to fund the entire
department there's not going to be
anybody to protect you and the people
are starting to go
wild and that's why i'm going to win the
state of minnesota i'm going to win
in the summer but you remember that
beautiful day it was
10 days late you had these people from
cnn and other places
these are friendly protests it's a
lovely thing to say
as as he's getting rocks and cans of
tuna fish
they go out and buy tuna fish and soup
you know that right
goya i hope he's great isn't it
quick guys they go out and buy goya
because
they throw it they throw it it's the
perfect weight
tuna fish that could really rip it right
and that hits you
no it's true bumblebee
brand tuna and you can throw that soccer
you can put a curve on it you can do
whatever that you want
and the cops in chicago you saw they're
going like this it was terrible and
they're not allowed to fight back
they're not allowed to fight back these
guys if they fight back nobody's going
to be there a very long throwing thing
but they throw but they're professionals
they're they're anarchists and they're
paid for by outside stupid rich people
that
they're stupid people and by the way you
know the first ones that get wiped out
if they ever they don't have a shot by
the way i tell you that but if they ever
did
the first ones that would get wiped out
are the stupid people that gave them the
money to do this stuff
those are the people that would get
wiped out but you know they're very
smart everything is perfect right you
ever see where they drop the bricks
along the thing in a bag and then they
drop everyone picks them up
throws them at our great police we're
not going to let that stuff happen
but this is all endeavor it doesn't
happen with republicans i was with greg
abbott i was with
ron desantis texas and florida
and other governors that can't even
believe a thing like that could happen
but they get caught they're walking up
there like 30 cans of soup
they have like 25 cans of tuna they get
caught i'm bringing this home to my
family
how dare you stop me no no no they use
it as ammunition
it's really it's terrible so we said to
the governor
we said we want to go in and we want to
take over portland it'll take us
literally a half hour maybe less
we'll march and you saw a little dose of
it minneapolis the governor finally said
go in we have the national guard and
remember that beautiful site
the street was a mess that idiot
reporter from cnn got hit on the knee
with a canister of tear gas right
and he went down i've been hit i've been
hit
he been hit the one with the shaved hair
shaved the head
maybe i'll do that one day i'll give it
up better shave it
but he went down and he didn't like it
he was hit
police brutality remember that what
these people were doing they're throwing
rocks they're throwing everything they
can at the place
okay now the national guard forums
and we just saw the one guy come out in
a black uniform right
the uniform costs approximately two
hundred and fifty thousand dollars they
got infrared stuff they got moth
equipped
and they walked in and they've got the
tear gas they've got everything you can
possibly have right pepper spray they
don't want you to use tear gas anymore
in some places like i think in milwaukee
they said no tear gas
no pepper spray how the hell do you keep
you know
big crowds back you can't so the police
all quit they all quit
they said we can't do it but you
remember they went out and you had one
then you had two three four then you had
five six seven
all of a sudden they started pouring in
they were getting off the buses
they came from a different locale and
then you had a line of them
and there was no social distancing
unfortunately in fact i was going to
turn them in because they were right
next to each other
they were all right dexter they were
touching arms and they had big strong
arms like these guys right over here
they were big strong guys that's all
right and they were like
together and then you saw the first line
then you saw the second line then you
saw a third line then you saw a fourth
one
and then they said march
they never halted just walked right
through cleaned everything out
and minneapolis was cured
they were they grabbed them
they grabbed them they grabbed them they
were grabbing them left and right
sometimes they grab they grab one guy
i'm a reporter i'm
a reporter get out of here they threw
him aside like he was a little bag of
popcorn
but no but i mean honestly when you
watch the crap that we've all had to
take so long
when you see that it's actually you
don't want to do that but when you see
it
it's actually a beautiful sight it's a
and they had the same thing on some
other streets and the whole thing was
gone and i haven't heard of any real
problem in minneapolis since that
happened i mean they were just burning
down the city and that
idiot was standing there this is a
friendly protest
and it's right and behind him was like
10 blocks of
fire was it's a classic i don't know has
anybody you know what i'm talking about
so i just have such respect but you have
to let these great professionals
do what they do best you have to let
them do it it's called law and order we
need law and order
it's a democrat phenomenon and if they
win
sleepy joe if they win because he has no
power over these people these people are
crazed
lunatics if they win your cities will be
like this
you'll lose all rights your constitution
will be worthless
it'll be a terrible terrible thing and
i'm not even sure
that after some time listening to that
and going along with it i'm not even
sure the country can ever recover that's
how bad it would be
i'm not sure it could ever recover over
labor day left-wing radicals rampage
through pittsburgh
harassing diners at restaurants i saw
that one that was
horrible
now i saw that right i saw that
that one guy grabs a woman an older
woman
she's eating a steak he grabbed the
steak and started eating it then he
threw it back on the plate
an outdoor place and the husband
standing there like
you know they're afraid for their lives
it was a terrible thing
that should never be allowed to happen a
thing like that should just be closed up
before it ever gets started
that was terrible remember that
[Applause]
your old an older woman last week after
a police officer shot a knife-wielding
assailant over 100 riders rampaged in
lancaster
went to school right nearby looting
businesses setting fires and assaulting
police officers with rocks and bricks
and glass you saw that
joe biden has the support of violent
left-wing extremists he never once
mentioned the words law and order during
their
entire democrat national convention
never once they didn't talk about the
riots
they didn't talk about anything having
to do with law
and order and respect and our great
police
they didn't do it they didn't talk about
it it's not a subject
they will rip your cities apart and they
will go to your suburbs for all of those
people in the suburbs that are reading
about
they will go to your suburbs next i have
the support of america's law enforcement
heroes
i was recently honored to be endorsed by
the largest group of police and police
representatives in the country we're
endorsed by everybody we're joined
by butler county mike
schrute thank you mike
as well as two sheriffs who just changed
their
registrations oh that's nice to become
republicans they were longtime democrats
oh that's
who are those two sheriffs whoa
[Applause]
thank you it's fayette county sheriff
james
custer and forest county sheriff
bob wolfgang where's bob santa fellas
thank you
[Applause]
were you long-time democrats how the
hell did that happen right
well this is somewhat of a phenomena you
know this is somewhat this is crazy
what's going on now
and it could be stopped so easily and
you guys know exactly what i'm talking
about thank you very much it's an
honor to have you in the party thank you
that's great
there's a whole great group of sheriffs
and law enforcement here
also with us are congressman guy
reshenthaler guy
where's god great warrior where are they
sitting
and a friend of mine and a warrior he's
a warrior he's tough as hell
they said we want to impeach the
president for making a perfect phone
call
oh did you hear today they want to pitch
me again they said if i submit the name
of one of the most talented people
in the world to be a justice of the
supreme court they want to impeach
me they want to impeach me
if i'm following the constitution
now think of it this is crazy nancy
these people are stone cold crazy
think of it i got impeached for making a
perfect phone call
perfect phone call everybody read it
nobody to this day
and the republicans stuck together it
was great also
a friend of mine and he wanted to just
rip him apart i remember when he heard
about it he's a rough guy
and he's a popular guy too they love him
congressman
mike kelly
[Music]
thank you mike come on up here come on
up here just come up
come on up bye come up come on guy come
on
and congressman glenn thompson
congressman dan muser
come on and congressman
scott perry thank you mike hey mike good
shape
come on man oh what a group
what a group thank you
thank you and we also have a
candidate here for congress this is a
candidate who is
the real deal he is tough as hell
he's no lamb
you know you know lamb i don't know if
you can get over that that this guy
could get over here rip it a part of me
they have big security over here that's
okay secret service
that's okay come on up here sean parnell
who has my complete and total
endorsement
this is the real deal
you know uh conor lamb is just a puppet
for nancy pelosi and crying chuck
schumer you know crying chuck he cries
every time he thinks it's appropriate
i'll tell you what this conor lamb
turned out to be a stone cold phony when
he was
running it's a very trump that they
liked me
and i thought he was a republican
because his ads were so good we have to
respect our president we have i said
this guy's doing some beautiful ads and
i found out he was a democrat
and i'll tell you what uh he's nothing
compared to sean sean is the real deal
and just give a little hand because he's
done a hell of a job to
our campaign chair bernie comfort thank
you bernie
bernie cup thank you thank you to bernie
comfort thanks
right while you guys are standing behind
me like a beautiful curtain well they're
not blocking air force one so we can
but i have a woman with us tonight
who has devoted so much she gave up her
business she said dad i'm gonna
come down to washington and help you
and i love you daddy and we're gonna
help people
and i don't care and she had a she was
very successful
in every way and it's my daughter ivanka
i just want to thank this group of
people and you know a man that helped
we just negotiated a major peace deal in
the middle east everyone said it was
impossible
you know that right they said it's
impossible they've been killing
everybody for years and years they had
this guy
john kerry who's grossly incompetent
they paid 150 billion dollars to iran
they paid 1.8 billion in cash that's
even more impressive frankly in cash
and that's john kerry and we just made a
deal
with bahrain and uae united
arab emirates and israel
and it's a great thing and the man right
there jared
ought to be abused
[Applause]
the abuse he takes but he did something
that nobody's been able to do and he
wants
none of the glory he'd rather not come
up here
these guys will come up 100 but
jared great deal great job incredible
everyone's talking about it we have
plenty of other countries
and there's no blood in the sand okay
thanks honey
[Applause]
great people thank you sean thank you
sean
we've spent the last four years
reversing the damage that joe biden
inflicted
over the last 47. they like sean sean
will you please win
sean carnell
[Applause]
just i'll tell you he's popular
that's great sean we love sean
but biden championed every globalist
portrayal of pennsylvania for half a
century he was a
cheerleader for the worst trade deal
ever made by any country
nafta and china's entry into the world
trade organization which built china
like a rocket ship they were flatlined
for many many decades and then
right through the roof that was a biden
approval too these disasters ripped out
one third of your state's manufacturing
jobs you know what happened
biden you shouldn't be asking for your
vote he should be begging for your
forgiveness he did a terrible job
now the democrat party is pledging to
rejoin the disastrous
paris climate accord you want to spend a
lot of money for nothing
eviscerating your state's economy you
will spend
a trillion dollars and what it is really
it takes away your power takes away your
energy
you'll be closing your plants and
factories all over the place
i withdrew from it and it was and you
know what
the people that understand the smart
people they said i can't believe you had
the guts to do it
and i see i figured i was going to be
absolutely killed on this one and you
know what
it's i'm so proud i did it and people
get it it was a rip-off of the united
states
i withdrew from the catastrophe
because i was elected to fight for
pittsburgh not for paris
[Applause]
this election is a choice between
pennsylvania
and china if biden wins china wins
when we win pennsylvania wins and
america wins
for decades our politicians spent
trillions of dollars rebuilding foreign
nations
fighting foreign wars that never ended
and defending foreign borders
but now we're finally protecting our
nation rebuilding
our cities and we are bringing our
jobs our factories and our troops
back home in the usa
where they belong all coming home
during the pandemic i've suspended the
entry of foreign workers who threaten
american jobs
as our economy reopens i want to ensure
that americans are first in line to get
the
great jobs and the high wages america
first
biden wants to flood the economy with
cheap labor
to replace u.s workers you know that and
that's why
never never i see him say higher
american he got it for me all the words
he's got they're my words
right do you ever see it they say he
copied my campaign
i keep saying what the hell happened for
47 years and now he's copying my
campaign
as president and you know it's not going
to happen with him
as president i know my first duty is
always to
take care of you the american worker
that's what we're taking care of
under my administration we've achieved
the most secure border in u.s history
and we are finishing that wall it's
going to be done so fast it's going to
be
done so fast since 2017 isis
successfully arrested nearly a half a
million
illegal aliens with criminal records
including over
145 000 assaults
40 000 sex offenses and 5
000 murders
if you don't mind democrats we'll bring
them the hell out of our country we'll
get them out of here
some of them are so violent we have to
keep them we don't want to house them
for 50 years
but if we let them go they come back in
as much as we watch you know
if they come back in we don't want it we
don't want them so we keep them here we
have no choice if the
left gains power they will abolish
republicans will always they're going to
abolish
republicans will always stand with these
incredible heroes of ice and
border patrol you have to see these ice
people they go into a den
of ms-13 they call medan a nest where
you have these
guys that are vicious vicious gang
members
and they go in there they just start
swinging it's the craziest thing they
love it
now who wants that job do you want that
job look he's a tough guy
setting it you too you're tough guys you
don't want any part of it they're just
incredible and they love our country
they love our country and then people
say oh they're too rough
they're so rough you have no idea how
bad some of these gangs are what they do
they use knives because it's more
painful
they cut people up they cut two young
beautiful girls 16 years old they were
going home from school
and they cut them to pieces killed them
they're animals we invested 2.5 trillion
dollars in the u.s military and launched
the first new branch of the u.s armed
forces
in 75 years space force not since the
yes
not since the air force think of it the
air force was last
if i did just that space force big deal
by the way it's going to end up being
one of the most important things you've
ever imagined but if i just did that a
sixth branch
of the u.s vote that would be a big deal
that's like one of many many things we
passed
va choice and va accountability
we killed the founder and leader of isis
al
baghdadi they were after him
[Music]
[Applause]
we took out the world's number one
terrorist and the mass murder of
american troops and many others
kasim salamani is gone
i withdrew from the last
administration's disastrous
iran nuclear deal one of the great
disasters
by the way you know it's practically
expired the crazy deal that obama made
practically expired and his chief
negotiator he never left
i want this nope we're not giving it you
okay let's go on to the next one
give me this nope give me this no give
me this nope he never won a point
he lost everything it's the worst deal
i've ever seen and the only time he left
the table
is to go on a bicycle ride
and he crashed and broke his leg in his
arm
and i promised everybody i would never
go riding in a bicycle race
i i swear to you
i kept my promise recognized the true
capital of israel and opened the
american
embassy in jerusalem
i also recognized israeli sovereignty
over the golan heights
that was a 52-year development that i
got done like in about a
day they've been negotiating that
sovereignty over the
golan heights i got it done immediately
52 years they worked on that
but instead of endless war we are
forging peace in the middle
east it's so great peace in the mirror
so biden's put forward a platform that
would end
america as we know it and this is true
you know i don't think of him as a
radical lefty but basically he's
controlled by them and what about this
kamala
how about that
she's at 15 no she's at 13
then people thought no she's at 12 no
she's a ten
she's at nine she's at seven these are
up whole numbers
she got worse and worse she quit before
she ever got to iowa
plus nobody including pocahontas treated
biden
so badly called him a racist right
brought him into the metoo movement
right
made him a member of the metoo movement
the thing she said
and i brilliantly said well the one
person he can't choose
is kamala
ladies and gentlemen i'd like to pick
kamala and she's rated
more liberal than bernie you know what
he's number two believe it or not
you know it's a true story she is rated
the most liberal
person in congress and i think she's
grossly incompetent i'll be honest with
you i don't think she knows what this is
and we have a great vice president mike
pence
and he says hello if elected biden would
destroy social security and destroy
protections for
pre-existing conditions people with
pre-existing conditions
drain your medicare by giving away your
health care
to illegal immigrants they're all going
to come in if you have that the problem
is
we're going to give you health care they
can all pour into the united states
and our country can't afford it we want
to be nice we all have hearts
country can't afford it they would get
people that never even thought of coming
if they see that
can't do it they would end our travel
bans on
jihadist regions we have very strong
remember i got travel bans everyone
thought it was such a terrible thing
such a terrible person he's such a
terrible person
i'm such a bad guy i got travel bans and
increased refugee admissions by more
than 700
opening the floodgates to radical
islamic terrorism
banned school choice and all charter
schools they're very important in the
second term i will provide
school choice to every parent in america
[Applause]
a vote for republicans is a vote for
safe communities great jobs
and a limitless future for all
americans all americans race color creed
all america
so in conclusion over the next four
years
we will make america into the
manufacturing superpower of the world
and we will end our reliance on china
once and for all
we will make our medical supplies right
here in the united states
right here in pennsylvania
[Music]
we will hire more police increased
penalties for assaults on law
enforcement
and we will ban deadly sanctuary cities
we ban banned
we will defend the dignity of work
and the sanctity of life thank you
we will uphold religious liberty free
speech
and the right to keep and bear
arms
we will strike down terrorists to
threaten our citizens
and we will keep america out of endless
ridiculous
stupid foreign wars
we lose our youth to countries that
you've never even heard of right never
even heard of them
we will maintain america's unrivaled
military might
and we will ensure peace through
strength
we will surprise and think of the
surprise medical building we're going to
end it
surprise you ever walk into a hospital
oh do you fix up all great then you get
a bill for two thousand dollars for a
mandate
we will end surprise medical billing
require price
transparency which i've already signed
and brilliantly starts on
january 1st hey you better vote for me
you know that's one of the i think
that's in a way bigger than health care
can you imagine biden if he won
what price transparency is so big it's
all done it starts on january 1st how
smart is that
how smart and you're going to see
numbers and reductions like you've never
seen
could you imagine if you were president
sir our medical costs have dropped in
half
price transparency has been unbelievable
what is that
what is price transparency they'll
explain to him he still won't have a
clue
but can you imagine giving him credit i
signed it it's all done
it starts on january 1st i said why
can't you start it now just in case
and you know what they said sir
statutorily it has to start that
i said all right let's go but i know
we're going to win so it's not going to
matter okay
[Applause]
and we're going to further reduce health
insurance premiums
and the cost of prescription drugs uh we
have our favorite nations laws
where now we get the same prices all
these nations that are paying a tiny
fraction
which should have been instituted a long
time ago and the drug companies are
going after me with those ads oh it's
terrible to everything you know why
just every time you see an ad from the
drug company plenty of money
that's why nobody ever fights them
anytime you see an ad from a drug
company just remember one thing your
drug prices are coming down that's what
it means
that's what i mean we will strongly
protect medicare and social security and
we will always protect patients
we will protect every single patient
america will land by the way
the first woman on the moon in the
united states will be
the first nation to land an astronaut on
mars
you know nasa was an absolute disaster
grass was growing through the
the fairways too they had fairways
that's about all they used with a
fairway
and now we have something right through
the the runways
the landing strips it was all grass
infested it was all weed infested
and now it's the number one space center
in the world by far it was a closed up
nest
[Applause]
the radical indoctrination of our
students and restore
patriotic education to us
we will teach our children to love our
country honor
our history and always respect our
great american flag
[Applause]
and we will live by the timeless words
in our national model in god we trust
for years you had a president who
apologized for america now you have a
president
who is standing up for america and
standing up
for the people of pennsylvania like
nobody has ever stood up before
so get your friends get your family get
your neighbors and your co-workers
and get out and vote
and early voting if you didn't know it
has already begun
and watch it and watch those fake
ballots you got to go out and
turn them in if they you see somebody
cheating you got to turn them in
from erie and you probably will it's
going to be a mess watch this
but get out and vote early voting from
erie to easton
from altoona to scranton from harrisburg
to right here in pittsburgh
say hello to big ben we stand on the
shoulders of pennsylvania patriots who
gave their blood sweat and tears
for their beloved country this is the
state
where our founding fathers declared
american independence right this is the
state such history
such history it's where the army
weathered its brutal winter
at valley forge i know it well where
george washington
led his men on a daring mission across
the delaware
and where our union was saved by the
heroes of gettysburg gettysburg one of
the
great great incredible sites
of history gettysburg
so vicious so horrible and yet so
beautiful and so historic right
incredible gettysburg pennsylvania
this is the place where generations of
tough strong pennsylvania workers
mined the coal work the railroads
forged the steel that made america into
the greatest and most powerful nation in
the history of the world
and we are making it greater greater
greater than ever before
not even close not even close it's what
we're doing
we're doing it together proud citizens
like you helped build this country and
together
we are taking back our country
we are returning power to you the
american people
with your help your devotion and your
drive
we are going to keep on working we are
going to keep on fighting
and we are going to keep on winning
winning
winning
[Applause]
we are one movement one people one
family
and one glorious nation under god
[Music]
and together with the incredible people
of pennsylvania
we will make america wealthy again
[Applause]
we will make america strong again
we will make america proud again
we will make america safe again
and we will make america
great again thank you thank you
pennsylvania
thank you
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
when
[Music]
it's fun to stay at the wise
[Applause]
[Music]
it's hard to stay
[Music]
[Music]
you can do whatever you feel
[Music]
but you've got to
[Music]
mca i'm
it's funny
[Music]
you can hang out with all my boys
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
someone came up to me and said the man
take a walk up the street it's a place
there
called the ymca they can't stop
my joy
down
[Music]
[Music]
blue
[Music]
blue jean baby
[Music]
[Music]
you must have seen
[Music]
now she's in me
always with me
[Music]
jesus freaked
out in the street
and then tickets are gone
[Music]
shout out
[Music]
looking on she sings the song
[Music]
the way she knows
i feel sorry lying here
with no one near only you
and you can't hear me
when i stand softly
[Music]
slowly
count the headlights on the highway
[Music]
[Music]
dance
[Music]
him
[Music]
[Music]
today
[Music]
[Music]
blue jean baby
[Music]
my
[Music]
[Music]
you must
[Music]
now she's in me
always with me
[Music]
[Music]
when i say softly
[Music]
count the headlights
[Music]
today
[Music]
on the highway
[Music]
[Music]
him
[Music]
yes
[Music]
the lord
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
hey
[Music]
[Music]
me
[Music]
channel one channel two
you